i had a guy i had a guy marvin delvaye
you know who marvin delby of course
so you're his hero okay
you he brought you up at the event in
front of 6 000 people okay he says
patrick i'm begging you if you can ask
this question he's a catholic
and he's a very very well-read catholic
okay
and he when i he's from honduras he's
done well for himself in business and
when i read this question for you you're
gonna realize how technical of a
question he's asking you okay
uh and and i'm curious to know what take
you know what your take is gonna be on
this it has to do with
a comment you made about the catholic
church right let me read this to you see
if i have it here we go okay
it's long-winded so just brace for
impact so
in his video
who dares to say he believes in god he
criticized the catholic church very
harshly
is not
uh the first that he had done and he
basically compared the catholic church
to the protestant approach to salvation
number one number two he then had the
opportunity to interview bishop baron as
part of his podcast name christianity
and the modern world and most of us
expect him to ask some really tough
questions about the issue he criticized
but he never had never happened
he almost looked overwhelmed by the
moment in the conversation he almost
looked like a man that wanted to confess
okay
first question he's got three of them
here for you number one
why did he avoid the tough questions
bishop baron was the best person the
most qualified person to clear what i
believe is a mistaken perspective about
the catholic church number two
he was also just coming back from a
difficult health situation he
experienced in 2019 did that influence
his approach to the conversation you
called me
the day of my birthday september 20th i
called him let me know that he was
really not doing well you when you you
know you
we knew kind of what you were going
through i was very emotional and was
praying for him ever since you have to
realize this guy's a true believer of
you number three my final question is
about the catholic church to which
catholic church is he referring to the
latin american catholic church that was
heavily influenced by liberty liberation
theology for the last 60 plus years by
the way very poor catholic church b
the very wealthy north american catholic
church see the european catholic church
that almost like
and angelican
church feels like a social club d
the grown missionary african catholic
church also very poor and persecuted
church the russian catholic church
suffering persecution by the russian
orthodox church the asian catholic
church persecuted by the chinese
government or the persecuted almost
decimated catholic church at the ease
his he talking is he talking about the
pre-vatican the second or the
post-vatican the second church is he
familiar with the current conflict that
emerged from the vatican the second
he made a blanket uh statement about the
catholic church which church is he
talking about does he know the
difference between them
between the missed opportunity with
bishop baron and
not being specific enough about his
position with the catholic church he
left a lot of unanswered questions where
do you stand with that
well one of the things i
learned from reading carl jung i mean
this isn't a statement he made
explicitly but
but it's
it emerges as a consequence of
reviewing a fair bit of his thought
his proposition in some sense was that
catholicism was as sane as human beings
could get
and it's a very interesting rejoinder to
the atheist types because they think we
could be rationalist materialists
but i don't think we can be because
that isn't what we're like
or we're all going to become rational in
in this scientific sense
it
there aren't that many scientists and
even among scientists there aren't that
many scientists it's actually really
hard to be a scientist you it takes a
lot of training
it's a very specific way of thinking
and
it isn't how obvious how broadly
accessible that's ever going to be and i
say that as an admirer of the scientific
enterprise
catholicism is a great drama it's a
inclusive encompassing
ritual and drama as well as a system of
beliefs and you know more power to it as
far as i'm concerned on that regard i
don't remember what my fundamental
criticism was unfortunately i there's
many podcasts that i've done because i
was so ill and sometimes well doing them
that i don't i don't remember them at
all
i meet people that i interviewed for two
hours and i don't remember meeting them
it's very distressing but that's life
um
i would say and i think the idea that a
critique should be differentiated that's
that's a very good idea and and fair
enough and i certainly don't
feel like engaging in a blanket
condemnation of the catholic church
i've i've been grappling
and trying to do this with bishop baron
too part of the reason baron wanted to
talk to me is because
the rel people who are actively engaged
in the religious enterprise
professionally and this is
orthodox jews muslims
orthodox christians roman catholics
protestants
protestants less so but some
they're
they're
interested in
the popularity of my
lecture series on genesis
because
i did that lecture series in 2017 it was
really the first public lecture series i
gave we rented a theater in toronto
privately
and
booked it for 15 weeks and i offered
these lectures and
all the tickets sold out and most of the
people who came were young men
and that's weird because you imagined
going to a bank with this business plan
so i'm going to run a thing i want you
to loan me some money i'm going to run a
theater i'm a professor i'm going to
rent a theater
and i'm going to lecture the first
lecture i'm going to give will be two
hours on the first sentence of genesis
and my target market is young men
it's like they're not going to lend me
any money that's that's a no starter but
the
lectures sold out and they've been
watched i don't know 40 million times or
something on youtube
and so the
the
civil apparatus of many religious
organizations are interested in this
because i obviously tapped into
something that they're not tapping into
and
my criticism if i remember was a
criticism
aimed at addressing the fact that that's
not being tapped into one of the things
i talked to bishop baron about and i may
not be addressing your friend's concern
because i don't know what specific
criticism he was
he was
he was concerned about
i suggested to baron that the reason the
churches the church the catholic church
is not doing as well as it might there's
many reasons is that they actually in
the attempt to popularize the faith
especially in the 60s they ended up not
asking enough of people
so we shouldn't ask so much like no
wrong decision meaning
expect okay make it more excessive got
it like got it yeah
okay one thing i learned from reading
kierkegaard you know kierkegaard said at
one point in real comical piece of
writing that once everything has become
too easy that there'll be a massive
outcry for
voluntary difficulty
and i thought that's smart well he was
smart he was kierkegaard after all and
the church can offer that
that is what it has to offer like that's
the straight narrow path this is very
very very very
very difficult but it's alternative to
hell
so there is that and i think that's
true and there's meta true and that's
meta true that's that's powerful because
you know
churches sit behind closed doors and the
board will say the whoever the board may
be at a non-denominational church hey
pastor this last time you talked about
you know pick whatever it is
transgenderism a little bit too much we
we're losing our you know attendees you
talked about this don't spend too much
time talking about gay marriage out of
the bible because we have to be a little
bit more diplomatic
you know don't let's not raise the
standard too much where people are doing
too many bible studies or too many you
know whatever you know events at the
house you're saying no double down and
raise the standards and keep them high
expect more from people that's what
you're saying
yeah absolutely and
and it isn't and not in a finger-wagging
sense it's more i've been thinking i've
been talking to a lot of
islamic thinkers and i have a lot of
people who
a lot of muslim people have watched my
biblical lectures like a lot
and so i have a following strangely
enough among the muslim community and
among orthodox jews and broadly among
religious communities
and
you know the christians are often on me
to come out and just profess my faith in
jesus christ as our universal savior and
um whenever i'm
let's say questioned in that manner it's
always a trap
it's like join my club it's like yeah
you just stay in your own club
and i've got lots of people to talk to
you know
but
a huge part of
you know the the muslims say it's pretty
funny
peterson doesn't realize but he's
actually a muslim and
and i had an
orthodox jewish fellow in new york
make a comment about his friends
watching my videos and
seeing them in accordance with the
deepest elements of their teachings and
it's a lovely thing to see it's very
surprising to me it's quite staggering
but
you know what i'm doing is predicated on
the idea that
there's way more to people than they let
out
and a lot of that's to be found in their
darkness
and i'm
making that case
i suppose the people who've been most
attracted by that case have been young
men and i think that that's because
they're so actively discouraged in the
expression of their possibility by our
culture
actively discouraged because
they're regarded as you know oppressive
patriarchs in training or some bloody
thing like that and so caustic and so
horrible i guess the question the
question i was more asking is
you know the idea is if we lower the
standards attendance will go up
we've been losing attendance because
standards have been very high let's
lower a little bit let's be more
welcoming you know and more political
religion isn't politics
it's
religion is that is the structure that
contains politics it's far deeper it's
like
politics literature religion that's sort
of the structure
so
politics literature yeah politics is
embedded well you know americans i said
you're all theatrical here well because
your whole polity is is encapsulated in
narrative everyone knows that that's the
american dream it's like what's the
american dream well it's hard to put
your finger on it and you guys are
exploring that all the time not least in
your popular culture
it's constant exploration of what
constitutes the american dream that's
the container for the political
structure and it's the dream that unites
you the political structure does as well
but it can't unite you if the dream
doesn't unite you and underneath so the
dream is that's in the domain of
literature essentially in storytelling
and dream and underneath that the
deepest strata of the literary endeavor
is the religious endeavor
the bible is a story
is it true well it depends what you mean
by true and people say well that's
weasely it's like no it's not
if you ask a profound question like that
is the bible true
you can't assume true and then cram the
bible into that you have to make both
sides of the equation open to question
what do you mean by true
well you're not answering the question
no i'm just not answering it the way you
want me to
i'm not this is why people like richard
dawkins always kick the hell out of
religious people when they're debating
them it's because dawkins comes armed
with a conception of the truth and it's
not trivial it's like the scientific
conception of the truth this is a big
club
and before he even
begins
this the whole structure of the debate
is predicated on
the fundamental acceptance that that
definition of true is
valid and complete and so the religious
people just lose because they're up
against the might of science it's like
how are they not going to lose that so
what do you mean by god is not great is
that
yeah
i've read it and by the way he he is
very very influential how he influenced
the world so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you